[Музика]
привіт хлопці пора
уроку англійської мене звати Наталія лашко
і мене звати Ольга Менма давайте почнемо
сьогодні ми продовжимо розмову про здоровий
спосіб життя
ми говорили про наше тіло і Ольга, допоможи
мені
що  підтримує нас у формі, що допомагає нам
підтримувати тіло,
звісно, це фізична ак
ивність це скільки ви рухаєтеся ва
і вправи ваші тренування всі ді
, які ви робите протягом дня, до
ре і що дає нам енергію о це їж
о так, я люблю їжу  я люблю їсти,
о, я теж люблю їсти, тому сьогодні
ми поговоримо про їжу,
о, я люблю їжу, я люблю їсти, а що з
тобою
фантастично, я також люблю їжу, тому
багато їжі багато інгредієнтів сьогодні я
не можу дочекатися, щоб  починай
так, почнемо добре, так, Ольга, допоможи мені,
я нещодавно набрав ваги, і я завжди
бачу твої ноги,
тож ти можеш допомогти мені, як ти тримаєш
себе у формі,
деякі люди думають, що я веган, у що
я не повірив би  я
вегетаріанка, я
знову не або дехто каже, що ти на дієті
я знову не я розумію, тож
як ти тримаєш себе у формі,
які правила, правила дуже
прості, як і все, що вам потрібно знати
про те, що ви їсте, щоб я міг сьогодні навчити вас
деяким
правилам, що їсти як  ходити по магазинах і
що готувати,
щоб підтримувати себе у формі
чому зазвичай
перед тим, як я почну їсти, я
фотографую це,
ти знаєш, що це як жарт, що не
так з твоєю їжею,
чому ти питаєш, тому що ти її не
сфотографував,
добре, скажімо, давайте подивимося, це
мій сніданок
о яєчня так, повний жирний сир
і
п'ять скибочок хліба, вибачте,
давайте, це мій обід о обід,
це знову ті макарони з усім сиром, а
як щодо овочів, де твій
салат, я не бачу його немає салату, вибачте, я
не  великий любитель овочів, як ви бачите,
добре, тому я збираюся шокувати вас своєю
вечерею
а тепер у вас є салат «Цезар»,
але це майонез так, це майонез, я
люблю майонез, що не так з майонезом
, це знову багато сиру з повним жиром, а
це знову багато майонезу.
кілька з
них на салат, але ваша тарілка
знову повна хліба, вибачте
, схоже, що все не
так, так, це не
так  добре, давай з твоїм,
як правило, я не
фотографую їжу,
але тому що я погодився провести цей урок
з вами, тому я сфотографував свою
їжу, добре,
добре, у мене є справжні фотографії, хлопці,
які були б моїм сніданком, ну добре,
виглядає  смачно, так, це пластівці з деякими
насінням і однією ложкою меду,
я бачу, так що без цукру, без цукру, без варення,
без шоколаду, без шоколаду, ну добре,
так, овес дуже важливий, ми поговоримо
про це пізніше, добре,
це було б моєю закускою, тому
іноді  у мене є sna  cks між прийомами їжі
виглядає як дуже гарний бутерброд, так,
фруктовий сендвіч, хоча
знову ж таки я не бачу зайвих цукрів, тому фрукти
повинні бути десь
у першій частині дня, наприклад,
перекус, так, а не
бісквіт,
я б схопив яблуко або банан.
добре, це був би мій фантастичний обід,
мені подобаються кольори зелений
лосось, я бачу трохи, і я люблю лосося,
так, авокадо і лосось, правда,
трохи сиру, але нежирний сир
я бачу, що з хлібом, чи все гаразд
?  все ще можна їсти хліб так, ви знаєте
крупи та хліб,
як ви згадували, це має бути
обмежена кількість так
правильно, і це був вечір, який
я приготував для своєї сім’ї,
це добре, мені подобається, мені подобається
поєднання м’яса та овочів
це запечені овочі так, це
запечені овочі
та раніше смажене м'ясо, додане до
страви
о, фантастично, мені подобається цей, я збираюся
піти з цим на вечерю сьогодні
добре, я поділюся з вами рецептом,
дякую  дуже
так, хлопці, ми підготували для вас текст,
тому ми хотіли б, щоб ви
послухали текст і
відповіли на запитання, щоб тепер ви могли побачити
шість питань на екрані
, прослухати текст і спробувати відповісти
на запитання,
готові, давайте
моя тарілка харчування
[Музика],
щоб бути здоровим, ви повинні їсти правильну
їжу для ваших енергетичних
потреб. Тарілка харчування добре показує п'ять
типів їжі
та в яких пропорціях ви повинні їсти,
щоб мати добре збалансовану та здорову дієту
фрукти та овочі фрукти  і
овочі
мають багато вітамінів і не
мають багато жиру або багато калорій,
п'ять або більше порцій з них щодня
допомагають вашому організму працювати,
а також боротися з хворобами зерна
рисовий хліб макарони картопля та інші
зерна
дають вашому організму енергію для всіх
речі, які йому потрібно робити
щодня, вони також мають багато
клітковини,
це допомагає вашому організму переробляти свої відходи
і не набирати вагу
молоко і молочні продукти молоко
йогурт і сир мають багато
білка і кальцію,
вони hel  щоб ваше тіло стало більшим і
сильнішим,
ці продукти багаті жиром, тому ви
не повинні їсти їх багато,
інакше ви можете отримати зайву вагу
риба, м’ясо, яйця та боби, ці продукти
містять багато білка та вітамінів
, необхідних вашому організму для вирощування риби
курка та квасоля краще, ніж червоне
м'ясо,
тому що в них менше жиру,
тому давайте обговоримо питання, тому Ольга,
допоможіть мені,
які види їжі нам потрібні для
здорового харчування,
ну очевидно, нам потрібні зернові каші
фрукти та овочі деякі жирні
та жирні продукти і, звичайно, обмежені
кількість цукру добре,
яку кількість овочів і фруктів
ми їмо щодня
відповідно до статей і
досліджень, ми повинні їсти щонайменше
п’ять шматочків фруктів і овочів на
день я бачу
добре, чому зернові важливі для вашого
організму
о, це очевидно  Перш за все,
дослідження показують, що під час їжі ми повинні мати принаймні
40 відсотків зерен на нашій тарілці,
тому що вони дають нам енергію, ми не
набираємо вагу, коли ми насправді
їдемо.  смак, зерно
та рис, але це дає нам всю
позитивну енергію, я бачу,
добре, давайте продовжимо, чому ми повинні їсти їжу
з білком,
наші білки – це риба, курка
та інші види м’яса
та яєць,
адже вони надзвичайно важливі для
будь-якого віку
однак особливо для дітей, тому що з
них
складаються наші м'язи, і
вони допомагають нам
рости, особливо маленьких дітей, я бачу
добре, дякую, давайте перейдемо до наступного,
чому багато жиру шкідливо для вас о,
очевидно, ми набираємо вагу  коли ми їмо
багато жирної їжі,
я бачу і чому ми повинні уникати червоного м’яса
червоне м’ясо є найжирнішим серед усіх видів
м’яса,
тому я не бачу, що червоне м’ясо обмежено, тому
курка
так, о, фантастично, я люблю курку, добре,
я бачу, що ви підготували завдання  для
мене так, у мене є дуже особливе завдання для
вас, але перш ніж ми перейдемо туди,
текст дав нам уявлення про групи
продуктів, які у нас є,
давайте подивимося на них, добре,
добре, давайте почнемо з вуглеводів
вуглеводи як ви  подумай, що
б належало до цієї групи,
я бачу добре, схоже на макарони, одні з моїх
улюблених
ах зерна, а також я люблю рисову
гречку, це добре, так, добре, а як щодо
хліба
так, це також належить до цієї групи,
ви маєте рацію, бачите,
можливо, щось інше  картопля, так, правильно,
картопля фантастична,
так, давайте розмістимо це сюди і перейдемо
до наступної групи, яка буде складатися
з
овочів так, я думаю, це легко, гм
, я можу назвати слова, будь ласка,
принаймні п'ять
принаймні п'ять це легко помідор огірок
баклажан ех перець червоний перець можна сказати
жовтий перець
о так добре що ще гриби
молодці добре добре зроблено що щодо
схожого щось подібне до
овочів що б це було
мені подобається ідея твоєї картини з
бутербродом так, ймовірно, фрукти
так ви маєте рацію  добре, фрукти та ягоди
належать тут,
тож давайте з фруктами, гм, бананами,
манго, ківі,
апельсинами та які ваші улюблені
фрукти, мабуть, банан був би моїм
улюбленим продуктом, а як щодо ягід?  рис я люблю
малину полуницю також
полуницю мій улюблений
гм я люблю агрус і
що ще червона смородина чорна смородина я
люблю всі ягоди
добре зроблені правильно давайте йти далі, зараз ми
переходимо
на молочний завод це, мабуть, йогурт
правильно молоко ну кисле  вершки
так добре, що ще масло,
ну, воно буде належати до жирів і олій,
добре, а як щодо сиру,
так, добре, йогурт я сказав вам,
чого ще я не знаю, допоможіть мені
сир, сир, сир, мій улюблений,
я бачу, що я  не великий шанувальник
сиру,
але я згоден, що ми повинні їсти його кожен
день, все
добре, зараз ми переходимо на білок,
як ви думаєте, що буде належати до
цієї групи
білок щось важливе, так,
мабуть, м'ясо
правильно курка, свинина  це добре,
так, що буде належати до м'яса, добре, гм,
що ще боби так, ви маєте рацію, а
що щодо горіхів, горіхи належать до
групи білків, а також добре, а
як щодо яєць, яйця також належать
сюди о, фантастично
виглядає, ніби я знаю цю категорію так  h, як
ми знаємо з тексту,
білок допомагає нам нарощувати м'язи,
надзвичайно важливі для маленьких
дітей,
наші учні так, погоджуюсь добре, і остання
група
добре, мабуть, мої улюблені жири так,
жири та цукор, вони збираються разом,
тому це буде вершкове
масло  це буде соняшникова олія оливкова олія
обидва добре, так олія, гм,
що ще, ну, оскільки ви згадали о
цукор,
так, мабуть, печиво, цукерки так
шоколадні батончики так фантастична кола
так вся фізика, це мені дуже подобається,
але чи можемо ми з'їсти це
так, але  якщо ви розмістите його зараз на дошці,
ми подивимося,
ми розмістили його в такому порядку не
випадково,
чому є причина, чому ми розмістили
це,
чому ви коли-небудь чули
про піраміду ніг,
ні  ніколи не чув про це, але
ви чули про піраміду
так, піраміду так, я чув трохи
хорошого правильно,
давайте побудуємо нашу піраміду, тому що найкращий
спосіб чогось навчитися - це справді діяти
, доторкнувшись до неї,
щоб побудувати її, чи готові ви так
добре, тому я так розумію  e, що ви
приготували для них багато їжі так,
я приготував багато їжі для нас, давайте
почнемо з кошика номер один,
добре правильно я бачу
тут багато дивовижних продуктів так
, усі вони належали б до першої групи,
що це було за вуглеводи
так  так щоб був би весь
хліб
добре французький хліб багет так
всі макарони макарони я люблю
макарони ти згадав це твій
улюблений продукт
це гречка гречана відома
їжа, яку ми любимо в україні не
хвилюйся так так це наша  улюблена
гречка о, ми називаємо це зернами
так гарна багата на те, що багата
клітковиною так і дає нам енергії
більше хліб, можуть бути різні види
хліба добре, що корисніше білий
хліб або
хліб з цільнозернового борошна.
містить цілі зерна, о, я бачу,
добре сочевиця, інший тип зерна
сочевиця
так, як ви знаєте, картопля, картопля,
так, наш улюблений, чи можна смажену
картоплю,
я б пропоную відварити її
або запекти чи запекти я бачу  добре, запікаємо добре
так, дуже добре, у нас є рис, добре,
гарний, гарний рис теж належить до цієї групи,
і він каже, що я люблю суші, о, добре,
так,
добре, більше макаронів, добре, і булгарський
бургер так, це одне з моїх улюблених зернових культур
вдома,
правда, причина  ми розмістили його, і
причина, чому ми почали з цього,
полягає в тому, що вуглеводи – це те, що має
бути приблизно в
шести
порціях зерна, макаронних виробів і хліба
на день, я бачу, тому нам потрібно їсти багато
вуглеводів так
добре, я бачу, добре, вони  побудуй наш раціон я
не проти макарони гречаний рис, це
чудово, я люблю його,
але чи можемо ми додати до нього трохи м'яса так, ми
будемо
додавати м'ясо, але ми будемо
рухатися відповідно
до піраміди так, наступний -
овочі  і фрукти так овочі
красиві кошики так, у мене є багато
так, ви щойно
назвали це баклажан баклажан правильно
добре, не могли б ви допоможіть мені, будь ласка, створити
ваш,
гм, я думаю, що це огірок, правильно,
добре, я бачу, авокадо це чудово,
і насправді е-е  це і овоч,
і фрукти,
так  добре, добре, я бачу гриби
добре, я збираюся покласти його сюди, я також бачу
спаржу, це красиво
так, так красиво, я збираюся покласти це так,
добре, у нас є кабачки так,
добре, і давайте з червоними кольорами, так
ми мали червоний перець
добре, о, давайте сформулюємо це так,
добре, пам'ятайте, що ми будуємо
піраміду, так,
я зрозумів ідею, тож давайте з такими
помідорами,
гм, більше перцю.
група овочів і фруктів добре, давайте ось
так
, все добре, так, добре, я бачу кілька
морквин
так, давайте покладемо їх сюди, а
як щодо яблук одне-два Ольга,
давайте на двох
добре, давайте з обома добре
і допоможіть мені, хлопці, будь ласка  що це,
так це помідор ні, це помідор і
гриб,
давайте візьмемо їх обох, покладемо їх сюди
ой, я забув про це, так,
наше улюблене питання Майк,
це брокколі, це брокколі, добре зроблено,
як ви зазвичай готуєте брокколі, гм,
я не люблю брокколі  ой тобі не подобається
Гаразд, тож, ймовірно, кипляча брокколі
так, прокип’ятіть її протягом п’яти хвилин так, бачу,
додайте трохи солі, і це ідеальна
порція овочів, я бачу правильно, так
що ми закінчили з овочами, так
, зараз ми маємо
вуглеводи, що складаються з чудової
пасти та хліба та  картопля, у нас є
гарний набір овочів і фруктів,
фантастичний правильний. Давайте перейдемо до щоденника
молочного добре, насправді це помилка,
яку більшість студентів робили б
молочні та щоденники так, тож правильним
є молочне молоко повторюється за
молочним, а як щодо щоденника так  щоденник
– це місце, де ти зберігаєш
усі свої таємні думки та ідеї щоденник,
тепер ми переходимо до молочного
сиру та всіх сирів я їх люблю, а
ти –
сир мені подобається, це мій улюблений продукт,
тож ходімо до молочної,
підбираємо те, у що ти віриш  я б належав до
я б пішов з цим що це
це сир я люблю мак і сир і я
зазвичай кажу
легкий сирний лимонний вичавлений о так добре, так
сир хороший,
що це за молоко фантастичне
, я можу сказати це  так, будь ласка, добре молоко, я
можу побачити ще трохи сиру, ось
це сир брі добре,
гм, молочні, так,
йогурт, добре, йогурт,
що ще мені взяти, допоможи мені, Ольга, у мене
є більше сиру,
так, блакитний сир, блакитний сир так, добре, ми
любимо блакитний сир
так, як ти  зауважте, що ми рухаємося по нашій
піраміді,
тому у нас багато вуглеводів, це
означає, що це не повинно бути
таким великим, як грип, так, якщо у вас є шість
порцій вуглеводів,
ви можете їсти до п'яти порцій
овочів і яблук
до трьох порцій  молочних продуктів,
і ми зараз переходимо до білкового білка
.  до групи білків
добре,
так як ми говорили про рибу
та м’ясо, тож ми підемо з рибою,
це сира сирова риба, це сира риба,
сира риба, добре,
і трохи м’яса, ви можете вгадати м’ясо
курка курка фантастично, дякую, Ольга,
тому яйця та яйця  яйця wi  Я належу до
групи білків
так, ви все одно повинні їх мати, але
обмежте кількість яєць, які ви їсте,
ви не можете мені подобається, як виглядає наша піраміда
так, це дуже добре, а як щодо майонезу, а
не тут, майонез не буде належати до жирів
квасоля
квасоля справді належить квасолі, давайте, деякі
люди, які вегетаріанці і не
їдять м'ясо,
вони замінять м'ясо квасолею
, це фантастично,
я також
спробую це зробити  лише шість
вузлів на день
так, це правда, і тепер піраміда,
як тільки ви побачите картинку у своїй голові,
ви пам'ятаєте, що матимете максимум
шість ночей на день я бачу чудово
, ми закінчили з протеїном я не бачу
нічого з вашого кошика, що  належить
до цієї групи,
так добре, і насправді кошик
зараз майже порожній, а
це означає, що все, що ми зараз будемо
їсти, це те, що ми взагалі не повинні їсти багато
, багато, привіт, так це жири, хлопці,
жири, давайте з нашим улюбленим  категорія,
але насправді нам це потрібно  обмежте це,
щоб я бачу багато печива
так, добре, тому ми не можемо з'їсти багато
печива,
ну плитка шоколаду добре
майонез майонез майонез майонез добре пам'ятайте свій салат
так, так, мабуть, гм без майонезу, мабуть,
я можу замінити майонез сиром
просто сиром  так, або оливкова олія
оливкова олія буде дуже здоровою,
добре добре,
солодкий напій
так, ми любимо газовані напої, добре,
деякі закуски, так, ви можете подумати, що я
їду горіхи,
але насправді у вас багато цукру,
цукру, жирів, не дуже добре,
так  і масло масло, ви все ще можете
додавати масло
до своїх страв, але невелика його кількість
вау, це виглядає як фантастична піраміда,
я збираюся її сфотографувати, щоб я
пам'ятав це добре, дякую,
фантастичне, і хлопці, ви можете побачити це зараз
просто пам'ятайте також про піраміду, що
дуже важливо з'їсти
таку кількість, тому пам'ятайте не багато
цукру,
скільки газованих напоїв ми можемо випити, щоб
пам'ятати,
намагайтеся уникати цього взагалі добре,
горіхи, пам'ятаєте, скільки горіхів
ми можемо з'їсти
о, я роблю шість годин  день так
гарний  nk, добре, і Ольга, ви можете
допомогти мені з цим, що це, ви можете
вгадати
молочні так молочні йогурти
добре і давайте переглянемо деякі вуглеводи
так, давайте зробимо і знову згадаємо,
піраміда складається зі скількох груп,
перша
справа, давайте почнемо з шести
порцій вуглеводів на день  добре
п'ять
порцій фруктів на день добре
три порції молочних продуктів три на
день
правильно дві порції
максимум риби і м'яса добре уникайте
червоного м'яса причина занадто багато жиру
правильно
добре і солодкої та жирної їжі
нуль добре, іноді ви можете її їсти  але
якомога менше добре
добре,
так що, якщо ми говоримо про групи овочів,
мабуть, я піду з
цією брокколі і що це за брокколі
брокколі, тому я збираюся готувати багато
брокколі зараз,
і я точно піду  гамбургер
так, а як щодо вашого сніданку, що б
ви зараз поснідали
на сніданок, я, мабуть, піду з
пластівцями, добре, з зерновими, я
приготую їх
заздалегідь, щоб я міг j  ми гріємося вранці
і їжте їх вранці так,
Наталія, наша піраміда не була б повною
без дуже важливого аспекту, який
один
ах озирнутися назад вода
добре так вода вода надзвичайно
важлива для нашого організму
так і скільки води ми маємо  потрібно
пити кожен день
добре, кажуть, що ви повинні випивати
принаймні півтора літра на день,
півтора літра, так це як
ця миска так
так добре, це добре, ви не повинні
пити це за один раз,
пам'ятайте  зроби це ти знаєш, пити
його між
прийомами їжі чи будемо у нас окуляри так, ви
повинні мати окуляри
я бачу добре я думаю, що я в порядку,
насправді я щойно встановив дуже
важливу програму,
яка нагадує мені пити воду, тому я
маю ремінь  як кільце,
і він показує мені, екран показує мені,
Наталія,
маєте склянку води о, ну, ви можете
поділитися зі мною,
звичайно, добре, подивіться о добре,
так, я також встановлю його, дякую,
так,
хлопці, ми дуже близькі  кінець
нашого уроку
і наше домашнє завдання  Ви будете малювати
свої власні піраміди,
тому відкрийте свій холодильник, знайдіть усю їжу,
яка у вас є, також
перевірте свої шафи, і ви можете
намалювати свій малюнок
або просто напишіть групи, ви пам'ятаєте
п'ять груп, Ольга, допоможіть мені
так, почнемо з вуглеводів, добре
тоді у нас є фрукти та овочі, добре
скоро у нас будуть ягоди фантастичний
сезон ягід я люблю це
добре далі ми переходимо до молочних продуктів молочні
продукти
зараз ми переходимо до групи білків добре, це
номер чотири,
а останній номер п'ять — жир і
солодкий жир  і цукор, який має бути
найкоротшою групою,
добре, тому я думаю, що ми закінчили, і ми
чуємо дзвінок, це означає, що нам потрібно
припинити урок
так і випити води, так, так, так
що приготуйте свою чашку, а ви, хлопці, випийте
склянку  вода також
дуже дякую до побачення
[Музика]
ти